- I heard that you actually met your
husband on the set of "Beetlejuice."
- I did, yeah.
He was a production designer,
designed all those wild sets
and they actually did redid
the whole house on the same
hill in Vermont for this second...
- For the second one?
- The second, "Beetlejuice."
But yeah, he was talking to me every day.
It was like high school, he's just talking
to me every day like, by our lockers.
And then he never asked me out
and then he went on to
prep the stuff in Vermont
and I'm grousing to Tim Burton about
how the production
designer never asked me.
And he said, "Let me see what I can do."
And I got there, first
day of shooting there.
Bo's off to the side.
Bo Welch is his name.
He comes over, goes, "Oh,
the art department's going to swap meet.
You want to come with us?"
- [Kelly] Wow.
- It's like he'd been forced.
- Really reeling you in, yeah,
- I guess.
But Tim was right, he made it happen.
- I love that, you got set up.
This is actually for some
reason tracks for me,
but like, as a gift, a wedding gift,
he gave you a tour of the Vatican.
- Tim did, yeah, a private, no, private.
- Okay, but I'm just like,
that is the most random
wedding gift I've ever heard of.
- And to me?
- How is it possible?
- Somebody had given it to him.
I don't know, it's a
very inside kind of deal.
- [Kelly] What was the...
- Okay, a priest took us around.
He got yelled at at one point.
I wish I spoke Italian, but he
was definitely getting yelled
at by another priest because
we were in the pope's closet.
Like, looking at garments
and stuff, it was crazy.
We were in the elevator that he takes down
to St. Peter's Basilica to do mass.
We were in this lovely
little, like a tiny museum
where all the gifts to the
Vatican from every country,
from every country leader in the world.
Gifts that had been sent to the
Vatican since the
beginning of the Vatican.
And this priest is letting us open cases
and pretending to put a crown
inside Bo's backpack, taking pictures.
I wish I had those pictures with me.
Just crazy.
- You don't have these pictures?
- Somewhere I do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh man, that's amazing.
- Yeah, it was beautiful gift.
- It's such a random gift, very memorable,
I'll give a that.
- You were rummaging
around the pope's closet.
- [Kelly] As one does.
- That's like, when you're like...
- I hate to say this out loud, sorry.
- Go into like, real estate or something
and you're like, oh, I'm
just gonna go like walk into
these open houses and you're
just gonna peek around
a little bit.
- No, no, yes, no, no.